In the next few decades,
the wells as we know it,
will change the loss.
This will of course bring many
opportunities,
but also many challenges more precisely.
Most of developed countries are facing
such a large threats that that response
may determine in economic,
political,
and social times which countries succeed
and which fail.
Folks,
I'm talking about population aging of
the demographic pyramids.
One hundred and 80 degree turn.
Yeah.
I'm sure this isn't news to you.
Most of you have probably already heard
about this subject.
However,
have you stopped to think about the
processes,
consequences on your government's doing
something about it?
Have they come up with something like a
contingency plan so you face the risks
that lie ahead?
I'll listen up world facing a new state
about a hundred years.
Our world has changed a lot.
It has changed so much that if we got a
time machines,
they some sort of special delorean and
traveled back two or three centuries for
a season sooner rather than later.
Most of us,
if not all of us,
would want to go back home really,
really fast.
We'd be missing loads of things.
Would be horrified by the day to day,
we'd be forced to work intensely harder
just to survive and we'd be afraid of
getting sick because we might die and we
might not even be able to eat.
But let's stay on topic.
Here it is.
At the end of the 19th century,
the world's population surpass the one
point 5 billion person.
Yeah,
I mean,
100 years later during the 20th century,
the world's population has multiplied by
four and past 6 billion of course,
considering the enormous speed with
which the world population group,
we can't be surprised by the fact that
many experts began to worry about of the
population and do you not think that
this was just a thing among mediocre
expert scientists and politicians?
Nineteen 74,
a report by the Secretary of State,
Henry Kissinger and Richard Nixon's
government to consider birth control in
countries such as Brazil,
India,
Mexico,
Columbia,
Ethiopia,
and Thailand as a top priority.
Cool.
Coming to the report,
the demographic explosion that was
taking place posed a serious threat to
the security of the United States.
Yeah.
With
so many people consuming resources,
Kissinger thought we were heading
towards a world of scarcity and fear
struggles for resources.
Have you noticed how Malthusian
arguments come up again and again,
even though they never actually
happened?
The fact is that while guys like
Kissinger try to think about how to
control the world's population and
influence their decisions to change was
already taking place.
Such a huge change that it would turn an
entirely new points in the debate.
In the last 50 years.
Welds fertility has halved so much so
that nowadays Western governments no
longer think about overpopulation,
but rather about aging today,
European countries and even the United
States tend to lose native inhabitants.
Check this out.
In Germany,
for example,
since 1972,
there have been 5 million more deaths
than births.
However,
the most extreme case has been that of
Russia were in just 20 years.
Between 1991 and 2011.
Then we're at 13 point one,
three more deaths than there were
births.
Future projections show that in the next
50 years,
Europe's native population will decrease
fire rounds.
One hundred million people.
No,
just that the other effect of this
entire process is that the world's
population,
especially if out of the most developed
countries is aging at full speed and
that my friends,
it's posing many,
many challenges,
pensions,
healthcare expenses,
dependence,
and the question is now,
how on earth can we finance this
gigantic expense to give you an idea of
what we're talking about here is
estimated that in many European
countries,
the percentage of the population over 65
years old will be around 40 percent by
2050 and one of those most effected
countries is actually Spain.
So listen up country of retired people.
Here's an exercise for you.
Let's assume that fertility in Spain and
the European Union remains within the
rates that they've had since the year
2000 and that's in addition.
No immigrants arrive.
You want to know what's going to happen?
Well,
check out the following week,
Ralph
and see if the population aged between
18 and 40 years,
which is the population that works the
most and the population that has the
most children.
That's going to take a huge dip.
Of course,
the number of inhabitants,
just a decade later that followed the
same trap.
Spain is one of the countries that's
beginning to suffer the most from this
demographic crisis.
The demographic crisis is getting worse.
Spain suffers it's biggest population
loss in 2017.
If we take a look at the average number
of children per women,
we can truly understand what was going
on here and this is taking into account
that the arrival of immigrants in the
last 20 years has boosted birthrates.
Nowadays,
23 percent of all children born in
Spain,
almost one in four have a foreign
mother fucker boss.
The most important data to predict
what's going to happen will come from
looking at how the number of people of
working age will evolve.
They after all other ones who generate
the vast majority of resources,
both public and private.
Well,
if we assume that there's no immigration
in just 30 years,
the working age population would
decrease by 10 million people.
It's according to the projections of the
Institute of Statistics of the
government of Spain.
Spaniards will face this panorama by
2015.
Okay.
30 million people of working age,
all of whom,
of course not a world work and almost 22
million children and retirees.
That is the dependent population would
be greater than the working age
population.
Yeah.
Now we're talking about Spain
specifically here,
but this scenario is very familiar to
most developed countries.
As you can imagine,
all of this has many consequences.
The consequences in recent times there's
been a lot of talk about the risk of
automation,
but perhaps the most imminent risk that
developed countries have to face is that
quick aging process.
At the end of the day,
it's clear that an agent population has
several consequences.
For one,
it's foreseeable that if nothing
changes,
public spending will skyrockets to pay
pensions,
healthcare expenses assistance,
and Kathy,
the elderly,
among many other things.
Pension spending increases by 50 percent
in Spain in 10 years,
and no doubt,
this will be very clear as a politician
and sleep hygiene,
many have retired voters will be
overwhelming.
It's simply a matter of votes,
but at the same time as we've seen,
there are going to be off.
You are working age people,
so the question is how on earth are we
going to pay for this huge expense?
Will the already high taxes be raised
even further damaging the
competitiveness of countries with as
many economic problems as Spain or
perhaps Italy?
Well,
the reality is that's a recipe that just
doesn't work.
Now at this point,
I think we need to answer a mandatory
question.
Well,
what the hell can we do?
We need a plan.
I know
and politicians don't usually like to
think about the future.
Especially future problems probably goes
a little something like this.
What I need to think about problems that
will happen in 20 years from now when
the risk losing votes.
No,
no,
no.
Let someone else take care of that.
Well,
if we don't want to see headlines like
this developed,
countries are going to need a plan.
Japan's finance minister tells elderly
they should hurry up and die to help
reduce countries rising.
Welfare bill.
The time to make decisions is now in
countries that decide to look the other
way and do nothing will face many,
many problems in the future.
You see lately here on visual politic,
we've talked a lot about immigration.
While experience tells us that this is a
good way to stop population aging and
buy time to make new reform.
As Australia,
Hong Kong,
New Zealand and Singapore have shown
integration can soften the blow from
rapid aging.
Sean Young Rhee,
director of Asia Pacific Department at
the International Monetary Fund.
Yes.
Despite many politicians discourse,
the truth is that developed countries
will need many people to arrive from
abroad,
so folks,
instead of thinking about building walls
and closing borders,
it would be much more advisable to start
a system that manages to attract people
from outside in an orderly fashion and
facilitates the integration,
but of course that's not all as public
pension systems will almost certainly
become much less generous because they
won't have as much of a budget.
Governments should also be promoting
saving both from the governments
themselves and from families.
Any Spanish political party warning
citizens of the next cut in their
pensions.
No,
they're all silent about our true
future,
giving a false impression that one
doesn't need to save to guarantee a
fairly dignified retirement.
Quander,
I'm on an IO economist and director of
the one day Marianna Institute,
and along with all of this,
of course governments should promote
policies that attract companies that
promote entrepreneurship and the bubble
that favor productivity investments in
machines and technology and in research
and developments.
Yes,
I think robots are actually going to
greatly help with this problem.
Unfortunately,
in many of the affected countries,
including Spain,
nothing has been done.
And finally before we finish,
I'd like to throw out an idea.
See,
the effects of aging is accompanied by a
longevity effects.
I want me to explain this.
Thanks to medical advances that
nutrition into quality of life mortality
rates for all ages,
so have decreased that his people a
younger for long see in the United
States.
For example,
the 75 year old person has the same
mortality rate today as a 65 year old
person had in the 19 fifties in Japan.
80 is the new 65
and also thanks to medical and
technological advances,
this evolution,
it continues to grow and grow,
which the humanity is fantastic.
Therefore,
if people have a longer,
more productive life,
wouldn't it be wise to encourage them to
continue working for longer and you've
even partially or in more comfortable
roles and that's where I'm going to
leave today's video,
but now it's your turn.
Would you be in favor of increasing your
country's retirement age?
If you're answering the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoy this video,
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts.
You provided the vocals in this episode,
but we're not mine.
Also,
this channel,
as always,
it's possible because of our patrons on
Patrion.
Please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next video.